[Music]
and welcome to Hannity and tonight A Lot
on Deck including a new scheme to get
Donald Trump Democrats they would like
to now use the 14th Amendment to our
constitution to remove Donald Trump from
the ballot forget the people deciding
they will decide we're going to get
expert legal analysis that's straight
ahead tonight plus James Comer Jim
Jordan they will join us with disturbing
new developments from Biden's weaponized
Department of Justice and their alleged
interference in the hunter Biden probe
where we have the highest levels of your
government being used to protect both
Hunter and Joe Biden at all costs and in
just moments ESPN hosts our buddy
Stephen A Smith he will be here with
more on why he thinks Joe Biden should
not be our next president apparently
supporting Gavin Newsom anyways not
alone in terms of not liking Joe far
from it all right look at this according
to a new Wall Street Journal poll 73
percent of you the American people you
believe Biden is too old to run for
re-election now the same poll found the
two-thirds of democrat they also think
Joe Biden is too old for another term
right on cue today the president got
confused in Dazed and well he walked out
during a medal of honor ceremony before
the event was even over please somebody
help this guy take a look
foreign
[Applause]
ladies and Gentlemen please join me for
the benediction
foreign
can someone show me where the ice cream
machine is Anyway by the way in a
half-hearted attempt at virtue signaling
well Biden is wearing a face mask once
again but apparently he takes it off in
crowded rooms looks like he's trying to
follow the science his version of it
anyway again or maybe the instructions
on the note card weren't very clear or
written in big enough font White House
staffers they're always telling Joe
where to stand what to do who to talk to
what questions to ask who to call on
what to say and probably what to wear in
the morning so today our very own peter
Ducey asked a very obvious question why
does the White House treat Joe Biden
like the big baby he is look at this
what sounded like a call for regime
change in rush to the president uh quote
rather than owning his failure he fumed
to friends about how he was treated like
a toddler was John Kennedy ever baby
like that so look I'll say this
um there's going to be a range always a
range of books
so look I'll say this
um there's going to be a range always a
range of books that are about every
Administration as you know that's going
to have a variety of claims that is not
unusual that happens all the time and
we're not going to litigate those here
that's something that we're not going to
speak to
the simple truth the complete reality is
this your President Joe Biden is
incapable of doing even the most simple
the most basic tasks so as staffers are
now forced to spoon feed him everything
Biden's mental and physical struggles
are also probably why he spent so much
time on vacation you know so far 40
percent of his days are spent away from
the White House a whopping 384 days so
far and he hasn't even finished three
years he is now on track to take more
time off than any other president in the
history of this country much of it at
the beach as you can see in his beach
chair which he struggles to pull around
and according to Joe he's actually not
on vacation that's what he said he's now
apparently homeless at least you can't
make this stuff up take a look
by the way
I feel hope to go to the secret service
has torn my house up in a good way to
make it secure so I have no place to go
when I come to Delaware it's up here
right now
now the Associated Press which usually
bonds over Joe Biden put it this way
quote I have no home to go to said Biden
who lives at the White House and
weekdays uh on weekdays and spends most
of his weekends in Delaware where he has
not one but two homes now despite all of
his days at the beach Joe still has not
found the time to visit the
environmental disaster known as he's
Palestine in Ohio has promised all the
way back in March by naturally told
reporters that he just hasn't been able
to get a break long enough to make the
30-minute flight from D.C to Ohio take a
look
well I haven't had the occasion to go to
East Palestine there's a lot going on
here and I just haven't been able to
break I was thinking whether I'd go to
East Palestine this week but I then was
reminded I've got to go literally around
the world I'm going from uh from
Washington to India to Vietnam to and so
I it's going to be a while
maybe a few less days on the beach and
and you'd be able to find the time
here's another more plausible
explanation Biden just doesn't simply
care about the people of East Palestine
in Ohio he'd rather be living it up with
Hunter uh at a mansion on Lake Tahoe or
in a beach in Delaware day after day Joe
only visited Maui after getting shamed
into finally acknowledging his innocent
four-year-old granddaughter and in both
Maui and Florida Biden obsessively
talked about what else himself comparing
the death the destruction to a tiny
small kitchen fire in his mansion that
was put out in less than 20 minutes back
in 2004. it contained by the way the
fire was contained to just the kitchen
not exactly the devastation Florida and
Hawaii have faced by boasting that he
almost lost his Corvette and his cat it
was horrible and between the lies by the
way the lack of empathy the sheer utter
incompetence Biden is hemorrhaging
support even among his base look at this
in 2020 Biden 170 percent of non-white
Voters in that election but according to
a New York Times Siena poll only 53
percent of non-white Voters now support
Biden in a hypothetical matchup against
Donald Trump Joe Biden will not be
elected with those numbers period end of
sentence now one well-connected
biographer with ties to the White House
is openly admitting that it won't be a
shock if Biden does drop out of the race
but it's not just his age and his
terrible leadership tonight Biden is
also dealing with very serious
corruption claims we call the the Biden
bribery money laundering allegation
Scandal that is simmering former senior
Trump advisor he'll join us in a minute
Stephen Miller he's now suing the
National Archives why he has to force
them to release Biden's government
emails related to his son's business
we're told that the last batch released
by The Archives they were fully redacted
in other words they were useless more
obfuscation more delays more lack of
cooperation but they're the most
transparent Administration in history
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else